foreign
comes from Tom in New York with the
growing cost of living here in the New
York City area I thought it was a good
time to ask my manager for a raise the
day after our meeting they offered me a
seven percent raise and I was ecstatic
an hour later they backtracked and said
my raise would actually be only three
percent I'm grateful for the raise but
this backtracking on the amount felt
like a slap in the face should I just be
grateful or should I try to negotiate
oh Dave this is uh some type of
leadership fail here poor leader yeah
this is just really bad I don't think
it's a slap in the face Tom I think it's
a gut punch and that's normal to feel
that way I don't think you can
renegotiate here because I think this is
a clear sign of a leadership error
somebody spoke out of their hat and they
couldn't deliver what they said they
were going to deliver so hat yeah that's
what they did well I'm trying to choose
the G-rated option for today's show
bleep you out of our own show exactly
that's family friendly folks uh but I
don't think renegotiation is the option
here I'll tell you what I would do I
want to know why that's what I would do
I think you got to sit on and go Hey
listen uh I feel like I've been kicked
in the gut and I I just want to know
what happened between the time you told
me seven and an hour later when you told
me three I think that's fair to ask
um because I don't know I'm not trying
to be ungrateful I'm not trying to be a
jerk but yeah I mean put yourself in my
shoes wouldn't you feel a little weird
about that so I feel a little weird
about it I want to know during the that
hour did I do something wrong no I
probably didn't so what happened okay
well I I overspoken my boss slapped me
down and made me you know maybe maybe
drop it to three because I didn't really
have the budget to do it okay that's
helpful to at least have that experience
that's correct and information right I
mean and so it still doesn't change it
all together you still get the same
amount of money but you know if you know
why then that makes a lot of difference
I think that's incredible advice there
because it's the gut punch it's still
there but if you know what happened and
you understand that sometimes people
make mistakes and they wanted to give it
to you I would be grateful in this
situation I would be grateful for the
three percent if it's a legitimate
reason
um
bureaucratic yeah that would bother
butthole answer I'm looking for a job
hundred percent
because here's what happens they just
don't do that right you know well yeah
we don't we don't give people seven
percent raises uh wait a minute you did
you said that's correct and that's the
difference between being valued and an
organization a healthy leader is going
to go I blew it dude I actually blew it
well they should have said that with the
they should have on the three percent
they should they should have not done it
start with but uh you know uh because
you don't stepped in it dude it is seven
percent and that's what happened here I
might kick the leader's butt that made
the mistake but uh but the guy's getting
his seven because we told him he's
getting a seven oh I was going to ask
you how would you handle that situation
I mean you know unless we didn't have
the money right if we simply didn't have
the money but if it's just a
Bozo thing then you know leader leaders
you know
I had one of our leaders um
we you know we we teach that you know if
you're gonna confront someone you talk
talk to them about the things they're
doing right we talk about this Behavior
that's wrong and then we talk about
things that they're doing right a
sandwich right it's not a one minute
manager thing right and um
uh you know and so you know you want to
you want to call it a uh whatever a
sandwich right so uh and uh one of our
leaders was fairly new and I just went
and said look that sucked don't do that
again and he goes where's the sandwich
[Laughter]
well you're a leader you get no bread
you just get the meat
that's funny that's weird if you're if
you're a leader you get you just get the
information right but you know I'll give
you the sandwich if I'm leading a
subordinate but I mean you just screwed
this up and you're supposed to be acting
like you run the place so oh my God but
yeah that's uh so you're eating the
seven percent out of your budget yeah
and uh in your area and we're gonna
figure it out but if if not if there's
absolutely no money and it was a truly a
financial error that has to be changed
then you've at least got to learn how to
uh
to explain something like this it
doesn't make it that much better it
makes it does it makes it a lot better
yeah it does a solid reason humans will
listen to yes honesty to say I messed up
I messed up and here's what happened and
here's what you know and I got you know
my boss took my freaking head off when I
went in there because I messed this up I
overstepped my bounds and it's so it's
on me it's my fault you own it and you
know that that's just like human this
quick leadership lesson here folks with
what Dave just said if you as a leader
don't own everything and give them all
the details that you can possibly give
them meaning you leave it as a vacuum in
their mind they will fill it with their
own narrative and that's where it
becomes toxic and dangerous you as the
leader got to make sure that the
narrative is correct yeah when in doubt
people don't believe positive things
without information they immediately
believe negatively I agree so these
companies that their communication is
mushroom communication keep everybody in
the dark and feed them manure it doesn't
work no it doesn't work that's Corporate
America though